. It is great to welcome back to the program,
Richard Wolffe, professor emeritus of economics
at my alma mater, the University of Massachusetts.
He taught me introductory macroeconomics a
long, long time ago.
Currently a visiting professor at New School
University in New York City.
The new book is The Sickness Is the System
When Capitalism Fails to Save US from Pandemics
or itself.
And you make the point in the book that I've
been making for some time, which is that the
pandemic exposed the inherent fragility of
many systems which we take for granted.
This includes the streams of income from our
jobs, whatever they may be.
This includes the food supply chain, as we
very quickly saw in grocery stores, toilet
paper, the inability of government, our government.
Others have moved far more quickly, but the
inability of our government to quickly react
to changing circumstances give us the kind
of big picture of what what the takeaway should
be.
Well, I think it's a stark illustration of
something which has been difficult for many
Americans to get their their heads around.
So let me be blunt and make the point that
the book makes in a variety of ways.
If you think about it, we all know that we
had a terrible virus back in 1918, killed
600000 Americans.
We know very well how damaging viruses are.
In recent years, we have studied Meurs, Saar's,
Ebola.
I mean, there is no excuse for a modern country,
let alone a rich one, let alone an economy
with a well-developed medical practice and
education system to be unprepared for a virus.
There really is no excuse.
And when you remember that an economic system,
if it has any priority, the public health
of the people who live in it has to be right
up there.
Number one, two or three.
Why in the world were we unprepared?
We had companies that can produce masks and
gloves and ventilators and all of that, but
they didn't do it.
And I know why I'm an economist when I study,
it isn't profitable.
No company wants to produce masks by the millions.
Store them in warehouses around the country
where the population is concentrated.
Make sure that they are clean.
Make sure that they don't deteriorate.
Replace those that do watch the whole thing.
And then you never know when the next virus
will be.
Will you have to sit on all of this for two
years, for six years or for 20 years?
So it's not profitable.
It's not a rational capitalist, profit driven
calculation to make.
So the companies didn't and we didn't have
the ventilators, the gloves, the masks and
all the rest.
And there is no shorthand way of saying it.
Private capitalism and the public health don't
work well together.
They don't solve the problem.
OK.
We could have had a secondary solution.
The government could have come in and said
what I just said, private capitalism is not
capable of making us prepared for a virus.
So we're going to do it.
We're going to buy the masks as fast as you
produce.
Did the ventilators, did other gloves.
And then we're going to store them at taxpayer
expense.
In fact, in warehouses and distribute them
and monitor them and clean them and replace
them.
We'll do all that because private capitalism
fails.
The government is going to come in and compensate.
But we didn't do that either because our government
is trapped in this ideology that somehow private
capitalism does everything maximally efficiently.
Maximov got it all wrong.
Well, they did have they did have the national
stockpile.
Right.
I mean, in a sense, that's what it is.
It was completely mis distributed.
And they did nothing with it for months.
But to some degree, isn't that what the national
stockpile is?
Yes.
And look, we have plenty of examples of where
the government can do it.
The best example that I use is defense right
now.
It's not profitable to make a missile and
store it for 10 years or a gun or a ship or
a plane.
But we do it and the government comes right
in, buys the thing as fast as the defense
companies produce it, and then the government
pays to store it.
Monitor it and clean it.
So we know how to do it.
But it was done because we're so ideologically
block that what we can do for defense we won't
actually do for our own personal public health.
We've been cutting back on rural hospitals.
We've been cutting back on that stockpile.
We have now shown ourselves to have what?
I mean, here's the statistic that I think
ends all conversation.
The United States has four and a half percent
of the world's people and we have 25 percent
of the world's colvard cases and colvert deaths.
We're a rich country.
That is a statistic that screams something
fundamental is wrong in our society with our
capability has such a record.
So on the economic response, which countries
did best in terms of dealing with the financial
insecurity, the job loss as a result of social
distancing measures that were, what are the
examples we should look to?
Yeah, I'm afraid that there again, I have
bad news, but it's bad news.
It's also a wakeup call.
Yeah.
United States did not do well.
Let me give you the starkest example.
In the United States over the last six months,
the richest people in the country gained tens
of billions more of their wealth.
Those numbers are well known.
I won't repeat them.
Over the same period of time, more than 50
million people had to file for unemployment
compensation either by the state or the federal
government.
I mean, a starker rendition of inequality
you could not have.
At the same time, we were all telling each
other, this virus is a great danger to all
of us.
We all have to work hard.
Together, we will get through this together.
Yeah, some people got through it together
by becoming richer.
And an awful lot of people are getting through
it by becoming poorer because of unemployment.
Why do I stress this in the European countries?
It wasn't done.
Unemployment in Italy during the entire Colden
period was less than it was a year before
that, when there was no cold in German, unemployment
went from five percent roughly in March to
six percent roughly.
Now, in short, in every major European country,
they did not do what the United States did.
They didn't throw tens of millions of people
out of work, throwing them on unemployment,
adding to their losses of unemployment, the
unspeakable anxiety of wondering whether they'll
ever have a job again, whether the job they
lost would be there when they went back looking
for it, which we all know.
Millions of them won't.
We already know that.
And so they're all wondering, is the roulette
wheel going to come down and point on me to
add anxiety to the worries about the illness,
to the worries about managing your children
who can't go to school, your distance, any?
It's unspeakable.
And let me tell you why.
In Europe, the reaction was so much better.
The European leaders, whether their right
wing, left wing or in the middle, they know
the following.
Labor unions, socialist parties, communist
parties, they're much stronger in Europe than
they are in the United States.
And that's been true for a long time.
And everyone there knows if you had dared
throw tens of millions of working people out
of their jobs, out of the security of their
jobs, they wouldn't have gone home to watch
TV.
They would have gone into the streets and
they would have shut down those economies
way more totally than any pandemic could.
And everyone there knew it.
So here was the deal in Europe.
The government will help you in your business,
but you cannot fire any one.
You get it.
That's the condition.
And that was accepted in Europe and that's
how they've handled it here in the United
States.
We don't have the political muscle on the
left in the labor movement to create a comparable
awareness.
So the Trump administration.
Good.
Go ahead.
The Democrats provided very little opposition.
Even the AFL CIO hasn't had a demonstration
to say this is taking out the difficulties
of a virus on the mass of people who have
no guilt whatsoever.
Why are they singled out?
Why is it possible to impose unemployment
on 50 million people while the richest people
gain billions?
This is beyond words.
And my book is an attempt to try to get at
how this came about and how it works so that
people can contextualize these awful results.
Yeah.
The book is The Sickness Is the System.
When capitalism fails to save us from pandemics
or itself.
We're going to go to a break on the TV and
radio show with Professor Richard Wolf.
But you'll be able to find our entire conversation,
which will continue on on the YouTube channel,
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.